- Hey, everyone, I'm really excited
to be launching a new
course, a short course
on an intro to data
visualization with R & R Studio.
So here is a short
lesson from that course.
Let me know what you think
in the comments down below,
subscribe to see more
videos that are coming up,
more lessons from this course
that's about to launch,
and be sure to pre-register
for this course
at the link below.
All right, well, thank you so much,
and with that, here is
a lesson on ggplot2.
Hi everyone and welcome to lesson six
in module four of this short
course on data visualization.
Now we're gonna be shifting gears a bit
and begin working on
a more advanced system
for data visualization
that we will be using
for the rest of this course.
So in this lesson, I'm just
gonna go over the basics
about how ggplot works
on a conceptual level.
We're not gonna do any coding yet,
though I will show you the anatomy
of how the code structure
and syntax works for ggplot.
All right, so let's get into it.
So the gg in ggplot stands
for the grammar of graphics.
The grammar of graphics provides
a more intuitive way to
create and customize figures.
Just like a sentence is based
around the combination of
nouns, verbs, and adjectives
and other elements that work together
to contribute different facets
to the meaning of a sentence,
data visualizations are made
of several key elements
that work together.
So the most basic structure
of a data visualization begins
with the data themselves.
Then various columns or variables
of that data set are mapped
onto different aesthetic
properties of the figure.
So for example, certain
variables are mapped
to the X and the Y axis and
then you have other variables,
in this case, variable three,
which is mapped to identify
the point color in the figure.
Anytime a variable is used
to describe an aesthetic
or visual component of
the figure in this way,
that is called mapping a variable
to the aesthetic properties of the plot.
And finally, those aesthetic
mappings need to be presented
using a geometric object.
So this is what determines
whether a figure will be
a scatter plot, a box plot, line plot,
or whatever other type of
plot you want to create.
So far, the three elements we've
gone over include the data,
the aesthetic mapping, and
then the geometry of the plot.
But you have many other
elements that might be
the coordinates of a plot, or what part
of the data you're gonna be showing
as well as other visual
properties of the figure
that don't particularly
have to do with the data,
which in this case is called the theme,
which might affect the font size,
the font color, et cetera of the plot.
So now let's just do a quick overview
of the anatomy of using ggplot
or the syntax of how ggplot
functions come together.
So first you begin with
the ggplot function.
Now note that the package
is called ggplot2,
but the basic function you begin with
is just ggplot without the two.
Then the first argument
to the ggplot function
are the data that you're
going to be using.
And note that I'm trying to maintain
the same color scheme here
between these different elements
and the actual code and
syntax here that I'm showing.
The next element of the ggplot
function is the aesthetics.
And these are the general aesthetics
that apply to the whole plot.
So for example, the most common aesthetics
are going to be adding
in using the aes function
are the X and the Y values.
So what aspects of the data map
to the X and to the Y
coordinates of this plot?
Then, this is a little different
than anything that
you've been doing so far
if you're familiar with the basics of R.
But then to add functions to
this, to add elements to this,
we're gonna just use this plus sign here,
add a new row, and now we're going
to add the geometry to the plot.
And this is where you can create a plot
that's just a scatter plot, a box plot,
or whatever other type
of plot you're creating.
But for the sake of this example
we're just gonna create a
scatter plot and that is done
by using the geom point, geom
underscore point function.
And within that geometry,
we can add another aesthetic element.
So again, using the aes
function, and now we can map
out different values
from the data to things
like the color of the points
or the fill of the points
or any other aesthetic property
that might be connected to the data.
And remember that because these points,
these different elements are connected
to different aspects of the data,
we literally, we make that connection,
we make that mapping by just saying equals
and then whatever the name of the variable
or the column in that data
that you want to refer to.
So in the original example,
we had variable one goes
to the x-axis, variable
two goes to the Y axis,
and then within geom
point, variable three goes
to the color of the points.
And finally, we can add another plus
and add whatever other
element we would like to add.
And there's many, many
different elements to look at.
Don't worry if this is a bit confusing
or if this seems like a lot to remember.
There's actually a really good cheat sheet
that ggplot developed.
There's a link that I put down below
to access this cheat sheet.
I actually refer to it all the time.
Here's my version.
It's kind of old, but there
might be an updated version.
So that is basically the anatomy
of how a ggplot function works.
All right, well, thank
you so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed and I look forward
to seeing you in the next lesson.
(upbeat music)